[Music]
thanks for joining us America we're glad
you're here - Keisha is with us in
Atlanta Georgia
hi - Keisha how are you I'm good how are
you
better than I deserve what's up in your
world frustration and irritation and
discuss exactly how I said it's how I
feel I'm a single mother I work two jobs
and I get paid pretty well controlled on
jobs my first job I make about 40,000
second it's about 30 before taxes I live
in Alpharetta I had my son little bit
early so we moved up here from the town
we were in because I can't continue
getting broken into I've been living an
outlet in this high rent I owe about
$40,000 in student loan debt with
interest and I read in a Bible simple to
even charge people interest but I have
so much interest in my student loans I'm
I'm just frustrated and they keep moving
up the rent in Alpharetta I can't get
ahead I'm so mad and I just need advice
like what to do because I don't know
what to do you understand what you do
for a living I do technical support good
okay and how far from Alfredo do you
live how do you work do you work I
literally across the street okay all
right so you're handy to work okay yes
and you're right that's a high rent
district you're in when I'm looking in
Decatur in the other areas I'm from
their rent is going up so pay someone
hard right and still get robbed it
doesn't make sense to me the cables gone
1,400 1,300 little projects apartment is
1,200 I don't get it okay the good news
is you make some decent money like you
said the piece of good news is you're
not afraid of hard work
you've just been feeling like a rat in a
wheel so long you're getting tired
yes sir I don't blame you don't blame me
a bit
okay so um and the $50,000 is killing
you I mean you got a big old student
loan debt Sallie Mae's got her own
bedroom that's why rents so high okay
all right so what we're going to do is I
want you to go through our one-year
membership program called Financial
Peace University it includes a nine week
group class okay at a local church there
I'm gonna pay for it I want you to go as
my guest okay I know you weren't oh if
you're expecting I know wasn't given
into it yeah sometimes people call like
that you know but anyway so you're gonna
go in there and the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to put you on
a detailed written budget now when we
sign you up for that
it's going to include a one-year
membership to every dollar plus and what
that is is our online budgeting tool
connects to your bank and it's going to
help you build a budget then when you go
into the class the coordinator will help
you with the budget too and everybody in
there gonna be just like you there'll be
some rich people in there and there'll
be some people in there that are in a
bigger mess and you're in but
everybody's frustrated and ready to
change okay okay and so you know it's
only nine weeks you only go there only
go to class nine times it's only nine
classes okay are not nine lessons right
and the in the group but the thing is
huh you you'll have some folks around
you to support you and walk this through
you because you know you've been
fighting this thing by yourself for a
long time and you just get emotionally
worn out yeah that's part of the
question so now once we do that when I
start doing your budget you have any
other debt like a car payment other than
that student loan I paid it off okay
good good all right so when I do your
budget I take food first out of seventy
thousand a year then I take out lights
and water so I've got electricity and
I'm eating okay
then I pay the rent and you got money
left after you do those things you're
just feeling stuck that you're always
going to be doing that only but what
we've got to do is we've got to squeeze
this budget beyond those three or four
things beyond just living we got to
squeeze it tight enough and I'll show
you how to do it okay but squeeze it
tight enough that you can begin to knock
Sallie Mae in the nose because she needs
me she's be hit in the face man we're
gonna knock her out I want to fight her
yeah we're gonna get ready we're gonna
give her her eviction notice
all right she's leaving so if let's just
say that we lived on beans and rice and
had no life and people thought you were
weird and everything else and you paid I
don't know
seventeen thousand dollars a year for
three years you'd be debt-free oh my god
I was thinking longer yeah I'm thinking
about how it's gonna work out I think
you're gonna you might pay it a little
faster than three years but it's
probably gonna take you about three
years now I'm talking about you got no
life here you're not gonna see the
inside of a restaurant unless you're
working I don't have a life now I've
been I don't even know half of it I know
well you've been you've been fighting
beer with us yeah you've been fighting
the bear with this which you've been by
yourself and you've been just swinging
at air and we're going to start making
contact now we're gonna start hitting
the stuff and I'm gonna show you how and
walk you through this you're gonna get
traction and it's not magical it's not
magical it's really hard work I'm
prescribing three years of a pain in the
butt but you've already got a painter
but we're just gonna change it I could
do it I could deal with it do you think
I should say am i doing the wrong thing
for me and my son's made up here I don't
know what's your winner how much is your
room right now my rent is a thousand
movies I'm moving out of the current
place one things are not because he
wants to move it up ridiculous and even
though I was ridiculous he wants to move
it up by 200 but he literally painted
over mold in my place and I draw it well
if you want to move that's
but I mean here's the thing the 200 is
probably not that unreasonable you're
part of what I'm hearing from you is
you've been beat on so much that you're
starting to feel like everything is out
to get you and it's not it's not they're
just me it's just landlord moving up the
rent it's not it's not now maybe maybe
this guy's a shyster he's painting over
mold I got that okay but I'm just saying
you know i dollars you can do in your
situation and still make progress 1,200
bucks you can do this don't make
progress but about what about 1,400
might be a little tough
uh okay the further we keep it down the
more we throw it Sally that's right so
the whole point is getting you know I
move you into a garage apartment over
the outback of somebody's house over the
top of the garage for three years if we
get out get rid of Sally right but I
won't do that for my life I'm just gonna
live like no one else so later I get to
live like no one else because I'm sick
and tired of being sick and tired
that's right and that's where you are so
you pay a price to win but not just pay
a price if you just move into a dumpy
place just to move into a dumpy place
there's no reason to do that but if you
can find a place that's safe well that
I'm in a dumpy place that's the thing
and it's a thousand who's going up right
you know I got you I got you okay but
I'm saying if we can find something
that's safe that is not appealing and we
can hold our nose for three years to
make progress on Sally that's what I
want to do I want Sally gone because
then we start saving to buy something
yeah okay and just as a side note
Ussery when it's referring to interest
in the bible is over charging interest
so like a payday lender would be Ussery
excessive interest is usury not just
interest so interest is not against the
Bible but excessive interest is against
the Bible so Sallie Mae is not excessive
interest and we're just gonna get you
out of it though we'll help you with it
hold on and Kelly will pick up and we're
gonna get you signed up for a whole year
membership in Financial Peace University
you can go to the classes online you
know the classes in person and you can
have the every dollar plus and we're
gonna walk with you and you call me back
if you're scared while you're working on
this I
walk with you you can do this you can
turn it around you got the stuff
main thing you've got is that level of
disgust that's a precursor to change in
your life right there this is the Dave
Ramsey show